hey there welcome to trying our best
kitchens is the Medal of Honor they gave
me for being the best at trying my best
no hi my name is very tall baby no no
you know your life is different now
welcome to another cooking video I'm in
my kitchen relatively clean I it's just
so soothing it's like a jegging on too
tight funds I went on Twitter and asked
you guys for suggestions because they
wanted to make a cooking video and a lot
of you suggested fourth-of-july
tech food a lot of you suggested
world-cup inspired dishes so today I'm
gonna do what I do best for two ideas
that shouldn't go together to go
together and see what happens
this one more than any cooking video is
uh oh I don't have my coat on my head is
like a jumble of Ultimate Ninja Warrior
course we're an initial seed of an idea
I can't just quite get to the articulate
audible explanation but we'll try what
I've been wanting to make cake pops for
a very long time cake pops are lollipops
made of cake they're very trendy right
now they lend themselves to the shape of
you guessed it footballs and/or soccer
balls and then I thought what is the
main ingredient and fourth-of-july
beer short uncle Vic says too many
things after being short Angela firework
injury from wanting to distract oneself
from what drunk uncle has recently said
sure but also hotdog so the goal today
is to make cake pops with a stinky hot
dog in the middle of that honor both
worth of July and the World Cup we're
gonna call it a World Cup wiener leave a
comment down below on the better name
for this i watched half of one video
today on how to make cake pops and I
feel like that's enough I'm just gonna
try like everyone that's in the FIFA
World Cup right now trying their best
and then they're clapping their hardest
you bake cakes and then you're gonna
crumble cakes and kind of fold in some
icing cake meatballs I have made my
favorite type of cake funfetti cake fun
fifa cake take it or leave it but also
pay your taxes oh I made this pic really
well look at this okay he's me but we're
supposed to do is crumble this cake till
mom all right
Oh cute I'm gonna save this one I don't
need all that Oh
pieces of end is stuck on my counter
because my dog has a cloth that is
bleeding and I just wrapped it up we
support cross contamination in this
kitchen our next step is that you add
like one or two scoops of icing to your
crumbly cake batter get it working
together I'm gonna start with one and
Louise's use your finger hey guys get
together oh this is weird this is a
weird feeling this is weird here this is
weirdest as we as we row it we're gonna
add a little bit more icing shout out to
my favorite store in the mall that was
too scared to go into because you're
close with too sexy for me in 1999
anyone else got the icing that was a
store for girls that like knew what they
were doing
so we're basically making it like up
heats a dough of cake batter I get it
I'm gonna clean my hands off
you're a backup goalie wait hold on wait
hold on before I do that I've never
heard of a name of a food that has more
innuendo in it than cocktail wienie also
known as beep little Smokies I don't
know look I'm looking too much delay
we're gonna cook these up and stuff them
into these cake pops and we're gonna
make the world come together right now
over we need to do is heat and eat that
was my dating profile my heart hurt so
I'm trying to make that joke heat these
on realtalk Wow yeah look it look like
at that look at that look at that yeah
all right
while the wieners cook let's talk about
flops what a slopping end or diving if
WWE could be 1/10 of Neymar's flopping
from Brazil you know win Oscars and
these Tony Grammys and all of you got
I'm heating up the tiny means going to
cool them down dust them in our funfetti
cake balls put them in the freezer and
then we are
just decorate them so they look like
soccer balls that is let's do how
Anthony big enough that they can fit a
wiener in their last leg I don't think
this is gonna work
right now I'm gonna take some white
chocolate l/2 it in this ninja bullet
cup so I can dip a cake pop sticks in it
here we go yeah Mike doesn't fit in the
microwave a smaller one oh my god oh my
god that's how easy this milk chocolate
butter and playing defense and offense
all at the same time okay we have our
cocktail wieners right here are now
going to oh my gosh Humira take you and
put them in the middle of every cake pop
maybe just as first right oh my god oh
my god oh my gosh she's in she said
she's in drawers we're gonna need two of
them spread take my white chocolate dip
it into our cake pop and let it set for
a second while we do the rest
oh my god this she works YouTube sorry
I'm out I'm starting a franchise of King
World Cup wieners where everyone's a
wiener man in goes the dynamite we're
gonna put our broke up weenies in the
freezer to set up for 20 minutes oh my
god this turns out okay I'm gonna lose
my [ __ ] brain already i won they're
delicious
bah oh wait I have to run to the corner
go okay we are going to melt some more
white chocolate oh it's been like 20-ish
take pops have a little fight - lets go
gosh we're gonna dip it in our white
chocolate oh my god these are way bigger
than a people we're just gonna try for
two beautiful dining Hana oh oh no now
I'm gonna fishies that I'm gonna make
one of these goddamn pops word I'm in
stoppage time Kona bad ambitious we can
salvage this this is so bad this is oh
wow you're working now
Oh as your dad and the audience Mel
Sunday evening like Ruby or so this is
what that thing was there for we got one
I believe it wanna put it in the fridge
of jails itself a little bit warm I'm
afraid
eautiful queen bee r15 you are yes yes
yeah I don't think she's gonna do okay
okay it's been a very brief amount of
time and I'm forward time to take that
woke up Queenie out of freezer it's okay
we're gonna draw some soccer stripes on
it really make it feel like it is the
masterpiece y'all hoped it would be here
we go
I am create here we have our beautiful
wonderful World Cup wiener pop
[Music]
but hey Brooke you wanna come try this
alright watch it's done
oh my god I know you're making a soccer
ball it looks like a soccer ball you
scream but if they don't think I was
making a soccer ball the click of the
bottom half of a lesion wait what Eddie
we're gonna play in the [ __ ] it except
none of us are trying to meet in the
middle and it go hard oh it's not the
combo when it hits it's sweetened so did
that shop do I have a mustache to wear
you look like a villain in a Pink
Panther movie Pink Panther oh this is
bad you get to the smoky Oh our tongues
are black like giraffes right now oh my
god smile at the camera
I don't like it ok now I love you no but
I'm the best when I'm saying like it has
nothing to do with you it's just like
the smoky is just too good and the cake
is too good and it's not a good combo ok
look at the u.s. right now we're doing
well that's right I'm become a political
channel on YouTube yes get on vote
November like it subscribe if you wanna
see more content I wanted to do this
because you know those FIFA players got
dumb cakes
it looks like the Raisin Bran side but
if he also was wearing headgear ready to
wrestle